[Música]
[Aplausos]
que el hombre sepa que el hombre puede
hacer
muy poco tiempo me enteré que esta frase
no era de mi padre sin embargo él
siempre me la repetía y me crié bajo
este concepto
me sirvió para superar una cantidad de
baches en mi vida y hoy me representan y
también representa lo que les vengo a
comentar
seguramente al igual que yo todos
ustedes tuvieron un sueño
y en lo particular
también tuve un sueño y era de volar
quién no
con 6 años aunque no parezca me la
rebusco con lo que tenía en mi casa para
hacer algo por mi sueño y
bueno agarre algunas maderas y construir
mi pequeño helicóptero
inmediatamente la gente que venía o que
acudía a casa
me lo hizo saber
que mi humilde creación no era capaz de
volar
y realmente lo recuerdo porque me dolía
y me hacía mal porque hacían bromas y
bueno
un chico
de esa edad no necesita que le digan
que su creación no iba a andar lo
contrario tiene que saber que puede
hoy quisiera ser el adulto que
necesitaba en esas situaciones
para poder motivar a esos pequeños niños
quizás esas palabras que me decían
estas personas hicieron que me aleje un
poco de la idea de volar
y lo hice me aleje pero si me queda un
desafío pendiente
siempre fui una persona o un joven como
un joven típico estudiaba iba inglés
hacía pocos deportes pero tenía muchos
amigos y sobre todo me gustaba ir a
pescar y para ir a pescar me financiaba
mis cosas haciendo pulseritas que las
vendía en el negocio de mi madre
un día estaba pescando en la costa y veo
que una persona en el medio del río lo
hacía de arriba de una lancha
sacamos más pescados y cuando miro para
abajo mis pies embarrados y digo no
quiero esto yo quiero hacer lo mismo que
esa persona estaba arriba una lancha y
ahí aparecen una cantidad de
contradicciones para comprar una lancha
no tenía plata
si quería ponerme a hacerla era un poco
complicado
tampoco tenía un conocido que me llegue
a pescar entonces
si tenía esa frase que yo sabía que
podía hacerlo de una forma u otra voy a
mi casa tomó fuerza y me pongo a
trabajar
con lo que tenía a mano
agarro unas maderas un nylon y unas
botellas
y fabrica mi canoa cuando la termino mi
madre se toma el tiempo de llevarme un
arroyo cercano y
bueno me pongo el salvavidas
pongo la canoa canoa arriba del agua me
subo arriba
agarró el remo y me alejo y estaba
flotando
ustedes no se imaginan la sensación de
estar flotando en esa canoa que la había
fabricado con nada
agarro el ritmo quiero hacer fondo y no
hacía fondo estaba realmente flotando
qué emoción cuando me doy cuenta que
quería poner las cosas de pesca no
entraba en ese momento me di cuenta
así que bueno fue un golpe de alegría
para seguir trabajando y fábrica y cinco
canoas más
y
más altas de que también me gustaba ir a
pescar
no deje del lado de las cosas que
andaban por por el agua por la tierra le
digo un día a mi madre que quiero hacer
una moto
y me dice estás loco
y yo por dentro decía bueno puede ser
que esté loco pero no comía vidrio
porque yo sabía lo que era capaz de
hacer
y con lo que tenía agarra un motor de
una cortadora de pasto
lo acomodó un poco lo hago marchar en
ruedas de bicicleta y ahí estaba
usted no se imagina lo que tuve que
pensar con ocho años para poder adaptar
un motor de una cortadora de pasto en
una moto
realmente desafiaba con mi mi
creatividad
y bueno hacía todos estos tipos de
d
máquinas como desde ahora se llamaba
porque era la única forma que podía
llegar a tenerlas porque comprar lo era
impensable así llegué a fabricar cinco
motos más y no deje de lado
las cuatro ruedas
tuve que fabricar algunos jardines
varios a pedales
y a los 14 años motor hizo el primero
lo usé durante dos años y hasta me di el
lujo de venderlo
y con una buena cantidad de dinero para
ese entonces me voy
a mi madre y le digo mamá me quiero
comprar un torno entorno es una máquina
herramienta de alto prestigio en el
ámbito metalmecánica y me dice que no
estaba muy convencida porque era muy
chico me iba a poner a trabajar iba a
descuidar el estudio
y bueno hablo con mis padres me dice que
con esa plata en ella compra una máquina
muy buena bla bla yo tenía esa frase que
yo sabía que podía hacer entonces me voy
a hablar con una persona que para mí era
un referente o es un referente y
y después de una larga charla me dice
cristian si te vas a confundir
confundirte vos mismos pero no dejes que
otros se confundan por vos
y me quedé pensando
entonces al otro día me acompañó este
señor a mirar el entorno miro las
condiciones me da el ok se renegoció a
las 5 la tarde estaba el torno
afuera de mi casa y pesaba una tonelada
o sea que nadie lo puede mover
era mío inmediatamente
me puse a restaurarlo
y empecé a trabajar a hacer una cantidad
de trabajos en general
el taller que estaba creando empezó a
tener otra mirada empezaron a aparecer
clientes la calidad de mis productos
incrementaron en gran medida podría
tener mucho más precisión en las cosas
que hacían y también tenía
empezaron a aparecer otros proyectos
como el que se ve en la imagen que me
permitieron hacerlos gracias a mi viejo
torno
y bueno
también llegó la hora d
de ir a estudiar esto lo había hecho
mientras que estaba en la escuela
secundaria
y sabía que si me voy a ir a estudiar
era ingeniería mecánica o nada
pero para ser sincero no tenía para nada
ganar ir a estudiar pero si sabía que si
también quería seguir con esto tenía que
estar habilitado y sin un título no
podía habilitar lo que eso hacía
así que
qué bueno me voy a estudiar pasaron dos
años que me la pasaba sentado y
realmente no me sentía para nada cómodo
estar lejos de todas esas actividades
que estaba acostumbrado a hacer de ir a
pescar de de estar en el taller
particularmente
yo necesitaba meterme en un proyecto
nuevo en algo que realmente desafíe de
vuelta a mi mi creatividad porque era lo
que estaba acostumbrado a hacer siempre
un día me voy a la ferretería que voy
siempre a la vuelta de casa y el
vendedor me dice christian cuando vas a
salir volando ahí adentro
entonces
me volví
me volví pensando y claro porque había
pasado mucho desde aquel entonces que
había apilado madera para hacer mi
helicóptero y entonces ya había
aprendido a mirar las cosas desde otro
punto de vista había dedicado mucho
tiempo en enseñarles a mis manos a
trabajar
y bueno decidí hacer un helicóptero un
helicóptero de una de las máquinas más
complejas que
que inventó el hombre
porque también aparte de todo esto había
aprendido a crear las condiciones yo
sabía que estando lejos particularmente
tenía que trabajar para luego hacer lo
que quería
si me venía un fin de semana acá tenía
20 horas como máximo para trabajar y la
mecha que tenía tenía que estar afilada
no me podía dar el lujo de ponerme
afilar la mecha
también había aprendido a controlar la
ansiedad
yo sabía que cada pieza lleva su tiempo
y que el sol no sale antes del amanecer
también no podía subestimar ni una tarea
porque siempre lo que pensamos que nos
va a llevar un pequeño tiempo no nos
termina llevando tres veces más
había encontrado cómo tener constancia y
en lo particular
fue porque buscaba esas tareas que me
permitían levantarme de la cama sin un
despertador yo no uso despertador porque
digo cuando estoy acostado que hago
durmiendo así tengo que estar haciendo
lo que a mí me gusta
después aprendí a disfrutar porque en
cada pieza que lograba o que iba
haciendo la ponía arriba del banco la
miraba y me hacía bien hacía sentirme
feliz así que bueno
también me llevó a disfrutar porque
conocí a una cantidad de gente una
cantidad de personas culturas oficios
que esto me llevaba a sentirme conectado
y también nuevamente me hacía bien había
aprendido a ocupar el tiempo muerto
sabía que un gran proyecto estaba
compuesto de una cantidad de objetos de
pequeños objetos de pequeños objetivos
que nos superan quizás los 15 minutos
cuando salgo de la facultad aprovecho a
venir
un tramo caminando para hablar con mis
seres queridos porque mi gran objetivo
por ejemplo es que la relación perdure
así que bueno todo esto me llevó a hacer
un helicóptero y lo hice al 100% 100% de
las piezas que fueron más de 500 y
bueno sin contar el motor y los
tornillos pero este lo había hecho en mi
propio taller con mi viejo torno es esta
ejército que lo monté desde cero y
también lo he hecho con mis propias
manos con mi propio de voluntades y
sobre todo con la gente que
que siempre me acompaña que es lo que
nos mantiene conectados y vivos
y bueno
[Música]
ah
[Aplausos]
bueno
[Música]
ustedes no saben la emoción que tenía
cuando estaba arriba no soy piloto la
primera vez que me subo en helicóptero
fue al mío
y bueno y hay una última cosa que le
quiero decir es que si hay alguien que
les diga que no pueden es porque habla
de sus capacidades pero no de las de
ustedes
[Aplausos]
[Música]